he is one of the most dangerous people
of my lifetime to ever be in the oval
oval office what is it that is causing
so many people to wake up well partly
what it is is that the mainstream media
has lied about so many things for so
long and finally we've exposed enough of
it that people are going well boy there
are some problems here now I want to
show you how they they sort of hate you
at that Elite level right the elites
sort of just kind of hate you and that's
exactly what Russell was talking about
here is Joy B from The View do we have
the uh there you go this next clip shows
a certifiably crazy person Joy bear
explaining that the rise of trump uh is
of course kind of like the rise of hit
that he is one of the most dangerous
people of my lifetime to ever be in the
oval oval office he is probably the the
most dangerous so you have somebody like
and he doesn't have a good sense of
humor we all know that at the
correspondence dinner when President
Obama made a joke about him
skin his skin is thinner than his hair
yeah and and and he got so pissed off
that he had to run for president and go
after Poor Obama who was born in this
country he is a menace so I present that
to this what are you supposed to do
problem is that the that hate and fear
are dividing things it pits people
against each other on purpose comedy is
uniting which is why comedy is always
where I go when things are the scariest
in life you need need someone to keep us
laughing about what
makes she didn't even say anything
that's true but have to she just made a
p no but but Sarah Sarah that is true
that's what I'm trying to say here but
the man doesn't take it because doesn't
it make it more funny they made fun of
Hitler Charlie chapler made fun of
Hitler in 1940 by 1945 millions and
millions everyone everyone else the
audience needs to laugh the people need
to laugh don't I don't care I'm not
checking on trp because he's so I need
everyone else to be but because he's so
thin skinned isn't it just funnier when
he's Mo but it makes him so angry it
makes him angry I don't know what he's
going to do next I mean make a joke
about him and he'll annihilate the whole
world yes he'll annihilate the whole
world the guy who again preco we can all
criticize him on the covid stuff
although for the most part he left it to
the states he he did a some screwy stuff
okay fine nobody's perfect uh but was
giving us the Abraham Accords was giving
us some at least talks with North Korea
Russia was quiet there was no invasion
of Ukraine but they they ramp this up
and really what they're ramping up uh is
is the fear so that they can stay in
control so when Russell talks about
these sort of Metropolitan intellectual
Elites he's talking about the joy bayar
types he's talking about how if you just
look what the machine produces it
produces a show like The View where they
have you know four or five lefties and
then just one pet Republican or or pet
conserv ative and how does that how does
that give you a snapshot of what of what
America really is it isn't but they
don't really want you to see what
America really is because they don't
like a lot of the people in
America